[Music]
things get awkward for Harry Styles as
he started his week-long residency on
Mondays Late Late Show with James Corden
we have a beautiful chicken coop and
lots of chickens they're all named after
the Kardashians as well so they're all
named after all manner of Kardashian
yeah yeah yeah are you gonna try and
make me remember them or Harry flinches
as Aaron taylor-johnson lists the names
of his at home chicken coop including
the singers rumoured ex kendall Jenner
so as a Kylie a Kendall corny Chloe Kim
Kris yeah Caitlyn
Kirsten Caitlyn oh you've really you
know you spread the wings yeah and it
core dig dig the car - ekans - lacunae
they have their own science nice and
they lay every day they lay every day
- oh yeah - they lay everyday Harry
despite the cringe-worthy moment fans
were in for a treat when the former One
Direction heartthrob took to the stage
for a moving performance
[Music]
and we'll hear more tune from Harry
Gordon tees and upcoming carpool karaoke
wit styles
you
[Music]